one cannery ship
three fishing trawlers gone forever to
Davy Jones locker one fishing pole one
wooden people
one Mack truck those things are not
cheap
that's a random building right there
cafe storefront fire hydrants aren't
expensive but they're important dammit
one straight leg Bowl another random
building destroyed traffic is at a
standstill emergency vehicles one
MetLife building that whole thing is
going to need to be redone what you got
there is a green for structural crisis
in your subway lines one Flatiron
Building aka the Daily Planet
Godzilla hates random buildings statue
damage to tanks
two military jeeps
one goddamn Chrysler Building one looted
electronics storefront get another
random building destroyed and another
Jesus two helicopters and one more
helicopter one bag of delicious candy
one subway car
the tanks are pretty worthless against
Godzilla's one USS Anchorage
one Madison Square Garden without
ongoing Bieber concert one chain-link
fence for dumpsters few alley another
light pole another chain-link fence but
this one's not Godzilla's fault one
opening of the Park Avenue tunnel
and one Brooklyn Bridge and now for all
the repeated damaged items you probably
thought we missed 58 cars damaged or
destroyed five boats destroyed 34
buildings partially damaged and damaged
from at least 325 Godzilla footsteps if
you're still in the mood to celebrate
all things Godzilla and why wouldn't you
be head on over to vsauce3 and see what
our buddy Jake has to say about the most
iconic of all movie monsters
you